La Dolce Vita with Alfa Romeo the most
Italian of car brands the company was
founded in 1910 and has a varied history
this 6c 2500 Super Sport dates back to
the middle of Alfa's hundred year
history it's a car that combines pre-war
motor technology with the aesthetics of
the early post-war era Alfa started
producing the 6c Series in 1927 and the
model was continuously updated until
1953 to keep up with the times
6c stands for Sasa Lindley six cylinders
this 1948 6c already had a two and a
half liter engine and 110 horsepower
right from the word go the engine was
equipped with dual overhead camshafts
but it's special cylinder head is only
part of the Alfa Romeo story the Kawara
sportivo is as popular today with
Italians as it ever was
Mauro kaput see who's a specialist in
Alfa Romeo says he's been driving and
repairing them for more than 30 years he
grew up with them his uncles all drove
Alfa Romeos and he was even driven to
school in one he praises them especially
as a great Drive saying they have a
fantastic sound are very fast and have a
long tradition
this 6c got it's bespoke bodywork from
the touring company in Milan and even
took part in the Mille Miglia
today it's estimated to be worth around
half a million euros
these are Fogler cop says these cars
roughen given these sublime kinds of
body work like this 2500 Supersport with
his short wheelbase only 20 or 23 of
them were ever built
they were the direct forerunner to the
villa desde la cama describes him as one
of alfa romeos crown jewel still today
at least where the six cylinders are
concerned although the bodywork is
constructed from aluminum making it
Superleggera the large alpha feels heavy
and it's steering takes a bit of giving
used to its pre-war vintage workings
mean the driver needs a sensitive touch
when it comes to switching between its
four gears
but not many fans would refuse to take
this car perhaps the most beautiful of
all Alfa Romeos
on the Mille Miglia
perhaps the best words to describe its
Art Deco dashboard a nostalgic flair
would be Cabella machina what a
beautiful car